[Musique]
à noter salue aujourd'hui on est le
lundi
lundi 24 avril il est à peu près 17h09
on est au lendemain du premier tour des
élections présidentielles et on connaît
le résultat
seulement voilà quelques jours c'est un
petit peu compliqué il ya eu les
élections tout le monde connaît le
résultat actuel avec d'un côté manuel
macro notre côté marine le pen
maintenant voilà de mon côté ça fait
quelques jours que j'étais en train de
me tracasse c'est que tout ça est de
savoir exactement ce que j'aime faire
[Musique]
avant toute chose ça c'est les bulletins
des personnes poursuivies pas voté mais
bien évidemment j'ai pris tous les
bulletins de conseils des bulletins là
dedans donc elle a forcément du ménage
avant de te dire pour qui j'ai voté
déjà te dire pour qui j'ai pas voté même
si c'est un homme physique il force de
la nature je n'ai pas voté pour
non désolé je n'ai pas voté aussi pour
monsieur 0 2%
c'est ça que je veux pas mais ça me
tente pas d'aller sur mars
non j'ai rien contre cette dame j'étais
pas partie des gens qui ont voté pour
moi labarthe auront plus à monsieur
poutou m en voulais pas/je rien contre
vous mais s'arrête pas en cours branger
à voter pour vous
beaucoup de respect pour toutes ces
personnes là mais je n'ai pas voté poêle
non plus tu peu facile de le faire comme
ça a forcément je prends les petits
candidats
après les récents cas d'un petit sprint
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas simple
[Musique]
ce qui se passe
à voter le choix est quand même super
super dure un mois ce qui est dingue
c'est que tu te rends compte que c'est
vraiment passés dans l'isoloir qui fait
le choix final mais c'est dur à faire
c'est un choix qu'il faut vraiment
vraiment vraiment durable
[Musique]
en réalité je peux le dire j'ai voté
pour
en ce qui me concerne ça reste le
programme qui me parle de plus c'était
extrêmement compliqué de prendre une
décision est de savoir si la personne
pour laquelle j'allais voter était la
bonne personne
si c'était la personne qui allait mieux
représenter la france pour présenter mes
idées c'est très très compliqué mais bon
un moment il fallait faire un autre
choix il fallait y aller et jusqu'au
dernier moment jusqu'aux dents longues
dans l'isoloir
jeffrey lurie noir jusque dans l'isoloir
j'ai pas réussi à trancher j'hésitais
vraiment rentrer deux personnes c'est
très compliqué et jusque dans l'isoloir
jusqu'à la dernière minute je serai pas
pour qui je vais voter c'était
extrêmement compliqué parce que l'enjeu
était de taille et le rendez vous était
vraiment de taille
[Musique]
je trouve ça super difficile sur cette
élection d'être capable de trancher pour
un candidat
alors il y en a c'est clair j'irai pas
mais il y en a un ou deux vraiment
j'hésite je trouve que c'est vraiment
compliqué sur cette élection d'être
capable de savoir quelle sera la bonne
décision parce que quelles que soient
ses opinions politiques quel que soit le
candidat pour lequel on va voter
ce qui est clair c'est que ces textes au
risque de changer beaucoup de choses
pour l'avenir en france et à
l'international
parce que si tu regarde ce qui se passe
en angleterre avec le break si tu
regardes s'est passé aux états unis a
collection de 30
c'est très clair que là il ya des choses
qui sont en train de se passer il ya une
donne qui change et ça peut être
relativement inquiétant en fonction de
telle ou telle personne de tel ou tel
courant de pensée ça peut être
relativement inquiétant et je trouve ça
vraiment flippant j'ai hâte et pat de
voir un petit peu les résultats de
l'élection ce soir à 20h 21h on voir un
petit peu à quelle sauce on va être
mangé ça va être compliqué de faire un
choix d'ici quinze jours je sais pas sur
quel candidat on va tomber
quels seront les choix qu'on aura à
faire de toute façon même si je suis pas
là pour parler de politique sur cette
chaîne
ce qui est très clair c'est qu'il y aura
forcément des déçus il ya forcément des
gens c'est pas du tout leur contenu là
qui va sortir et est ce que ça sera la
même chose pour moi ou pas ça on sait
pas toujours est il que l'enjeu est
énorme et j'espère vraiment que
le président ou la présidente sera à la
hauteur de la fonction parce que dans
tous les cas ça reste quand même
relativement relativement inquiétant
pour l'avenir
la france est vraiment attendus sur
cette élection présidentielle et ça
risque de donner le coup aux démocraties
à venir avoir effectivement sur quel
type de deux solutions sur quel type de
gouvernement elle se dirige
et c'est en ça que ce vote est quand
même hyper crucial est hyper important
est qu'il faut pas se planter
il ya un vrai rendez vous en ce moment
et ça au niveau international
c'est emmanuel à 23 tu as vécu moi mais
les quelques minutes avant avant de
connaître le nom des deux candidats
retenus pour le second tour santé une
espèce de tension monte en moi parce que
je mesure vraiment l'enjeu et c'est
hyper angoissant
alors je dis pas que vu que je vais pas
de dévoiler en réalité pour qui j'ai
voté
je ne vais pas te dire si si je me sens
plus léger aujourd'hui oui ou non
toujours est il que il y avait vraiment
cette angoisse et au moment des
résultats
ces thèmes est hyper anxiogène ça c'est
typiquement le genre de débat que tu
peux avoir pendant des heures avec tes
potes tu peux parler tu peux parler
politique essayer de comprendre mesurer
et non les aboutissants mais de toute
façon il est sûr qu'à des tonnes de
choses qui nous échappent et des choses
qu'on peut pas mesurer aussi facilement
qu'on le voudrait les implications les
répercussions qu'est-ce qui se passera
après en tout cas moi je ne suis pas
particulièrement un spécialiste j'ai
beau me intéressé essayé de me
renseigner le plus possible s'est jamais
réellement hyper évident mais bon il ya
deux mois quand il faut y aller il faut
y aller c'est l'appel des urnes il faut
y aller on a un devoir civique à faire
même si je sais qu'il ya des gens qui ne
veulent pas aller voter qui prend une
pause au dessus moi je considère qu'il
faut y aller on a aujourd'hui une
responsabilité par rapport à ça et à
temps il ya un second tour qui va se
tenir d'ici quinze jours un petit peu
moins de quinze jours d'ailleurs c'est
un rendez-vous hyper important on a le
choix entre deux candidats je veux pas
de prise de parti j'ai déjà dit c'est
pas le sait pas la vocation de cette
chaîne dont que je prendrais pas de
position par rapport à ça par contre la
seule position que je les prendre c'est
d'aller voter pour exprimer une des
trois possibilités soit voter pour un
candidat soit voté pour l'autre soit
voté blanc parce que de toute façon il
faut faire entendre sa voix et c'est
relativement important à mon sens
d'être présents et de répondre au rendez
vous disions donc fait le bon choix les
amis 1
soyez sages votez bien je vous embrasse
et que le meilleur gagne mais vaille que
vaille quoi tu prends talent mais tu
recherchais
[Musique]